Speaker 1: a single completely standard generic
Democrat crushed for right wingers on Fox
News related to the FBI search warrant served
at Trump's Mar a Lago.
I'm talking about Jessica TARLOV.
I'm like no big Jessica TARLOV fan.
She's intelligent.
She's a completely standard Democratic Party
apologist, not someone whose political views
are super exciting to me.
But I have to give her credit.
She holds her own when she goes on these Fox
News programs.
She was on a program called The Five where
there are I guess it's like there's four sort
of hosts and then a fifth person who they
often put in the middle.
As you can see here, in this particular episode,
it was right wing bomb thrower Dan Bongino,
who was brought in.
And every single person on this panel, I believe
it's going from left to right here.
Dagen McDowell Then it's Jessica TARLOV, then
it's Bongino.
Then I believe that that's Dana Perino, although
there's like 50 different, you know, blond
news women on Fox News.
And it's a little zoom, zoom that I can't
tell who that is.
And then on the far right is Greg GUTFELD.
All right wingers.
The topic is the search warrant served at
Mar a Lago and they try all of them to use
these very often repeated but factually incorrect
talking points about Trump complied with the
subpoena for the documents, but actually he
did all these different things.
And TARLOV is taking it from all sides and
fending it off quite well, I have to tell
you.
Speaker 3: President has had to comply with.
And why now?
Because they subpoenaed him in June and he
did not comply.
Now, you know I'm.
Speaker 2: Not making that.
Speaker 3: Up.
No.
Speaker 1: She's not making it up.
The Trump lawyers claimed that Trump complied
with the subpoena, but the FBI knew better
and they knew they hadn't gotten the documents
back.
It's sort of like if you say, I am bankrupt,
that doesn't mean you were bankrupt.
You can claim to be bankrupt.
I'll go even further.
The Alex Jones example you can file for bankruptcy.
That doesn't actually mean that you were bankrupt.
It just means you have.
You've made a legal assertion that you are
bankrupt.
Trump's lawyer said, We gave you everything
they didn't.
Okay.
So that there's there's one aspect and then
it just continues.
Speaker 2: Here you are.
He actually met with them on June 3rd, according
to multiple.
Yes.
Speaker 1: And they're meeting with someone.
Understand the subterfuge and the distortion.
Meeting with FBI agents doesn't mean you complied
with the demand to return all the documents.
These are two different things.
And Jessica TARLOV realizes.
Speaker 2: That actually met with them on
June 3rd, according to.
Speaker 3: Multiple.
Yes.
And then after that, Jane Pratt, who was the
agent involved in this, who does oversee it,
was like, wait, it was six weeks since the
end of June and that's okay.
Speaker 1: So then they interrupt her.
Now Dagen McDowell comes in with look at how
look at how slowly they moved.
It took so long for them to act.
Speaker 3: It was six it was six weeks since
the end of June.
And that was the last communication.
What's was last target, if it was so urgent?
That was a challenge.
It was there a subpoena ignored by the Trump?
They had to.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Dagen mcdowell is now using another talking
point.
This is a very common talking point they're
using, which is if this was so urgent, if
it was so urgent and of national security
consequences that Trump had these documents,
you know, in his toy, later in his bathroom,
wherever he had him at Mar a Lago.
If it was so urgent, why did they slow play
it so much?
Why did they allow six weeks to go by between
the the June 3rd meeting and serving the search
warrant?
This is one where they want to have it both
ways.
Imagine that.
The FBI did something totally different.
Imagine that the FBI didn't give Trump the
six weeks.
They just went in and went looking for the
documents.
These very same right wingers would be saying
this is not a way to treat a former president.
They should have done it through lawyers.
They should have given the operative, given
him the opportunity to return the documents.
It's too aggressive to go in so quickly.
So do not fall for that talking point.
They're saying the FBI moved so slowly it
couldn't possibly have been of security consequences
if the FBI moved quickly.
They would have said that's an inappropriate
way to handle an investigation into a former
president.
And again, Jessica TARLOV just doing everything
she can to refute this nonsense.
Speaker 3: Subpoena ignored by the Trump.
They had conversations after the subpoena.
Why multiple conversations with no survey
have hyped, you know, whether they complied
or not.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So, again, the question is, did they comply
with it?
Just because you had conversations after the
date doesn't mean you did what the subpoena
instructed you to do.
And then just one other really funny moment.
Bongino couldn't help but bring up Hillary
Clinton.
And I really like how Jessica TARLOV here
looks at her watch and says, Wow, you made
it 9 minutes before mentioning Hillary.
Speaker 2: So on the Democrat side, Hillary
Clinton literally my hand.
Three, we are in spy paid for 9 minutes to
produce a hoax about this.
And you're highlighting the Democrat Party
as a paragon of don't.
Speaker 3: Make me laugh.
Speaker 1: They can't help themselves that
this can't just be about the facts.
It has to be about Hunter Biden's laptop or
when Hillary Clinton, OxiClean emails or whatever
the case.
It can't just be about the facts and really
nice job they're done by Jessica TARLOV.